[Applause]
so
what's the story so basically chelsea
handler was talking to jimmy fallon
and uh that's a conversation you got to
hear
i mean who could miss that jimmy fallon
and chelsea handler
uh and she basically was like i i had to
remind 50 cent he's black
in terms of like who he should vote for
because 50
excuse me tweeted out the thing like 62
percent tax in new york i'm not going
with that [ __ ]
yeah so chelsea goes i gotta remind him
that he's black now
chelsea as a as a comic because she used
to be a stand-up
yeah that's a joke yeah but
because she's woke chelsea now yeah and
she's policing what people can or can't
say or can or can't do
and she's not giving comedic license to
other people
she is victim of the same scrutiny
that she's giving those other people oh
okay i think that's what's going on here
if she was
funny i'm a drunk girl i [ __ ] whoever i
want i'm wild girl back in the day and
said that do you think she gets a single
bit of pushback
yeah but nobody cares it's like that
pushback that nobody cares about people
it's not a national story everybody's
like shut up it's almost like oh you
don't understand chelsea like she just
says wild [ __ ]
and that's funny i don't i haven't paid
any attention to her since she hasn't
had a show on e or whatever yes
so i still thought she was that person
so you
looked at it and you were like yeah
that's her yeah she's like
that's why i was like the story was like
nothing and because she even follows up
trying to say some [ __ ] like
uh and i would [ __ ] him up she didn't
say it but he's like i would do whatever
it takes to get him to vote
for biden yeah she's willing to [ __ ] him
yeah
they're already funny yeah but like as a
joke right
and it's like okay yeah that's that's
what you're going for some funny it's
not the
best joke in the world but it's not bad
it's fun it's like yeah you're having
fun
the pushback on this was crazy which
really shows how much people resent
chelsea for like going woke um and
why is it what nevermind go ahead no go
ahead
what okay what was your question i guess
i guess
that's what i think the reaction is like
people are so pissed off
when woke people start to make jokes and
i get that also because it's like hold
up
you're gonna attack the people i like
when they make jokes and then you're
gonna think you're gonna make the same
jokes whenever you want
that's not gonna happen and i do
appreciate that
on some level i understand where that
comes from you're like don't
don't be mrs joke about race all of a
sudden and then be woke as [ __ ] didn't
she do that show on netflix what was it
called like
which one uh when she learns not to be
racist or some [ __ ] she did like a
series
chelsea learns or something i think she
like went to india she did do something
like
it was chelsea that did that yeah yeah i
mean it's crazy to see her fall off once
she went woke
like that turn once you go woke you go
broke like al just stop listening to her
once you stop making fun of like short
mexicans
remember when she had that guy chew it
was it chewie on the show yeah yeah that
was hilarious
yo he took he must have written for her
or some [ __ ] bro like he took all her
funny bro
to the grave dog bring back chewie
that's what she needs
that's why she don't want the wall
that's why she hates trump
she's looking for a new chewie yeah yeah
oh my god probably fit underneath the
wall underneath but he's not climbing
that [ __ ]
no no no no no oh my god now we
understand it
why are you saying that she's woke
though like she's never
i thought back in the day she was
absolutely hilarious i mean that
sincerely like i thought as an
interviewer she was excellent
i didn't really watch to be honest with
you i would watch it yeah i think she
was funny she was funny dude
why do you think she's not the same
anymore though it seems to me i haven't
really been following her that much but
it seems the public sentiment around
chelsea is like shut the [ __ ] up you're
like some woke girl that like switched
up and
yeah and her like most recent tweets
she's just not like on twitter like this
is what trump's doing in
a pandemic vote him out to save humanity
i just don't know what they think
they're doing
like why do actors keep tweeting about
politics clearly it doesn't work nobody
cares what you have to say trump won
four years ago
and now you're tweeting more like it
helps i think i think there is a certain
politics you have to have to exist in
hollywood
and it's we're like detached from that
right because we don't realize that
they're
there might literally have like an in
crowd in hollywood
and they might really believe that like
they could dictate the pace
of the cultural conversation by the
movies and tv shows that they make they
might like overvalue their importance a
little bit
and so they're like oh you don't have
the right politics you're not going to
be involved in these conversations
maybe that's why once once you go woke
you go broke when it happens
nothing it always does but when it
happens it's like yo we see through this
like stop trying to push this [ __ ] on me
can i just watch a [ __ ] movie please
can i just be entertained without you
pushing this on me [ __ ] this movie i'm
not
watching it also we don't like being
lied to bro but if we think if we feel
like someone's lying to us
we feel a way about it and i think i
think this is why people reacted poorly
a lot of times to when
uh when actors would come out as gay
after they were famous
it's not like i hate gay people it's
like i thought i knew you
yeah and now you're not the person i
thought so i don't even know who you are
like
i can't say i love you like i don't know
you i think don't get me wrong there's
tons of homophobia and people probably
usually sure whatever but i think there
was a certain part that was like
oh dude like whoa like when you find out
ross ain't ross
yeah when you find out like you're like
your favorite character isn't
who they actually are when you find your
favorite actor's an [ __ ] you're like
oh you're not the guy
that i thought you were not that being
gay is negative or whatever but it's
like oh i thought you were this this
whole time i thought i knew you
turns out i don't know you at all ellen
the biggest pushback in the world is
about ellen is because everybody really
thought wow you're like this sweet
person that you make me feel good you
make me feel happy i'm glad you're
trying to be nice to people and then you
find out you're just a [ __ ]
everybody knows that interaction with
ellen that went bad was like really
bothered by it yeah and i think it's
expectation and reality yeah
expectation was so like high for ellen
and she was just
kind of [ __ ] yeah right to work at the
ellen show
you used to work there no i wanted to
you want to look
because it looked like a phone call
you're surprising people out of nowhere
but what if
i still know the whole thing with this
whole ellen thinking what is this sense
of people that don't like to be scared
because that's what seems like she's
like a lot of people that's what the
whole thing is
no no no no no taylor she's not mean to
the guests
she's mean to me the source is different
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
like you get different news
yo what taylor's referring to anybody's
listening is you know how like ellen
scares people on the show yeah so she
thought all this drama about ellen was
yeah people that worked there
too yeah but she thinks this whole drama
is that people from the show is like
i don't like being scared you know
jumping out of nowhere
i don't get a warning it's a horrible
work environment
that's really weird i carry coffee
sometimes
yo white taylor is crazy bro
what's crazy or a whitetail or a piery
taylor why taylor a red tailer what's
great
you do not want [ __ ] red taylor is is
almost like that's like the red wedding
right there that's red wedding
that's right it's like the massacre red
taylor's around it's a massacre
it's like the bottle of malbec that went
into al's foot yeah
[Laughter]
i don't know any any other thoughts
about this whole chelsea [ __ ]
no no because it seemed to be such a big
story why do you think
i don't i think it was just good fodder
for people that was like this liberal
white woman telling black people what
they had
i think white people are having their
comeuppance i think this is
their this is their they're getting
their punishment for skating by on
their privilege and just letting y'all
throwing you all under the bus on the
heels of bill burke calling white chicks
out
i think that was the beginning of that's
the beginning this is the tipping point
now you're gonna start to see it yeah
chelsea goes on late night and it's like
black guys you got
she goes i gotta remind him he's black
as if like he got some white girl [ __ ]
to do
poor al can't even have sex with a white
one without her reminding him all the
time
what's funny is when people watch clips
of this and they see you and full white
face
yeah and you guys in white face and they
have no clue why
we're just talking about random [ __ ]
like kanye's not really worth three
billion dollars
but no context whatsoever to what's
going on you look smarter though
well thanks guys
you